[Music]
hello and welcome to movie clips
mixology Oscar edition today we're
making adorable minion and evil minion
cocktails equipped with purple cotton
candy for the evil minion hair for your
evil purple minion cocktail you will
need Collins glasses shot glasses for
measurement a shaker ice triple sec Blue
Curacao coconut rum cranberry juice and
purple cotton candy first you will need
to add eyes to your shaker next pour in
1 ounce coconut rum add 1 ounce triple
sec add 3 ounces cranberry juice
finally add 1/2 ounce of blue curacao to
get that awesome purple color mix up all
your ingredients in your shaker strain
your drink from your shaker into your
glass for a finishing touch add purple
cotton candy on top for an evil minion
hair for your good minion cocktail you
will need vodka peach schnapps and
pineapple orange banana juice because
minions love bananas first you'll need
to add eyes to your shaker pour in one
ounce of vodka add one ounce of peach
shop's to the mix finish it off with 4
ounces of the pineapple orange banana
juice
once you're done shaking strain your
drink into your glass for an adorable
finish you can add black rubber bands or
tape and attach googly eyes to your
glasses now all that's left to do is
serve and enjoy your minions
[Music]
you